[Música]
momento de hablar de salud aquí en
directo a América de France 24 por ello
me acompaña en el estudio mi compañera
Natalia plazas Natalia Buenos días
Buenos días Valentina vamos a hablar de
un tema bastante complicado y es la
contaminación en el agua en Estados
Unidos que esto pues tras décadas de uso
de algunas sustancias químicas
sintéticas que son muy difíciles de
degradar y que pues sin embargo se
encuentran en objetos utilizados a gran
escala entre la población como lo son
los sartenes recubiertos de teflón sí
Valentina estamos hablando concretamente
de las sustancias
perfururo alquiladas o polifluoro
alquiladas también son conocidas como
las sustancias para siempre porque no
son biodegradables y porque una vez que
entran en nuestro en nuestros cuerpos es
muy difícil de eliminarlas para abordar
este tema nos acompaña la doctora Roxana
Trejo Gonzalo médica epidemióloga y
especialista en salud pública el estudio
realizado por el servicio geológico de
Estados Unidos de tectó estas sustancias
en casi la mitad de las muestras tomadas
que fueron unas 700 en todo el país
doctora nos puede explicar un poco de
qué se trata Qué son estas sustancias
para siempre y por qué llegan a nuestros
organismos
Hola cómo están un saludo desde México
bueno primero esta sustancia se utilizan
como ya lo comentaban ustedes son los
químicos que se utilizan en la industria
pero en muchísimos lugares en los
alimentos también se utilizan para
estas espumas para los incendios se
utilizan en telas para repeler que se
manche no que de repente estamos muy
felices porque tenemos una ropa que no
se mancha Bueno pues ahí también están
estos químicos y al final todo esto
llega al manto freático y al llegar al
manto freático Pues contamine el agua
contamina el agua contamina los peces y
también tenemos mucho material en la
casa que cuando compramos una pizza
puede ir en este cartón mucho material
que hoy estamos seguramente hasta en la
ropa hoy tenemos ya este material en
contacto con nosotros cuando cocinamos
ya comentabas sartenes que pueden tener
teflón para que sea más fácil de limpiar
o de retirar el alimento Entonces esto
es una sustancia que que desde más o
menos 1940 se empezó a utilizar por la
industria ha pasado un gran tiempo en
relación a el contacto con ellos y creo
que es el momento de como población
poner el ojo En relación a la salud ese
es un tema muy importante de estos
químicos bueno y justamente le
preguntamos Cuáles son los riesgos para
la salud pues de para la salud de las
personas de estas sustancias
Bueno fíjate que en estudios que se han
hecho en el laboratorio con alguien
animales se han encontrado que tienen
impacto por ejemplo
en productos que tienen bajo peso al
nacer en el sistema inmunitario o sea la
respuesta inmunitaria hacia las
infecciones puede ser retardada también
se ha encontrado casos en animales en
laboratorio de de cáncer en estos
animales al tener un contacto continuo y
también se ha observado en algunos
estudios también en animales que puede
alterar la función Pues de de la
tiroides por ejemplo también puede haber
un desarrollo no normal de algunos
órganos como el hígado puede ser como el
riñón y también se ha visto alteración
en relación a por ejemplo a los a los al
colesterol tener un nivel es mucho mayor
de colesterol también por supuesto tiene
que ver con estilo de vida pero se han
encontrado que estos químicos puedan
alterar la salud y creo que es un punto
importante Nosotros también al consumir
o al comprar cosas decidir que qué es lo
que sí compramos y es lo que no por eso
es importante ponerlo en la mesa
doctora Roxana para las personas para
las que ya se ha detectado que tienen
estas sustancias en sus organismos Hay
algún tipo de tratamiento para ayudar a
que las puedan segregar
Pues en este momento no lo que podemos
encontrar mientras no hay alteración de
las células mientras estos productos no
hayan ya alterado las células como el
sistema inmunológico o algún otro órgano
lo que se puede hacer es que normalmente
hay una circulación continua en la
sangre no y al tener una circulación
continua en la sangre nosotros podemos
ir algunos de ellos desechando por los
filtros que tenemos en el cuerpo pero al
final hay que detectar claramente que
qué es lo que al consumir ciertos
productos puede ser alimentos o puede
ser el mismo agua y entonces tenemos que
detectar y creo que estos estudios que
colocan en la mesa donde detectan en el
agua pues hace también que los sistemas
que avasen el agua a diferentes este
pues habitaciones o colonias puedan
tener un sistema que filtre para que no
llegue a la persona porque cuando llega
la persona se nos complica más el tema
del control de la salud creo que lo
importante es desde que se establecen
lineamientos En diferentes gobiernos
decir a ver estos productos no o ustedes
tienen que controlar o no deben de estar
en la en lo que se fabrica y ya existe
en Estados Unidos toda una regulación en
relación a este tema es un programa
importante para reducir estos productos
pero si no hablamos de Estados Unidos
sino de todo el mundo de latinoamérica
Pues todos los países deberíamos Ya
empezar con esta regulaciones para
empezar a controlar que ese producto no
llegue al consumidor eso es una y otra
evitar la contaminación del manto
freático que al final va a llegar a la
pero mire con lo que usted estaba
diciéndole preguntó por qué pues hay un
estudio realizado de 2015 por los
centros para el control la prevención de
enfermedades en Estados Unidos que dicen
que estas sustancias se encuentran en la
sangre del 97% de los estadounidenses
esto pese a estas regulaciones de las
que usted ya estaba hablando entonces
ante esta situación que persiste pues
Qué deberían hacer las autoridades para
evitar que las sustancias sigan en el en
el ambiente
Sí claro es ese es el primer punto
porque al tenerlos ya en el cuerpo de
las personas esto se dificulta en
relación a poder eliminarlo porque
continuamente podemos seguir consumiendo
y dejando esta entrada es el cuerpo o
sea lo primero que tendría que hacer los
gobiernos es sí establecer que los
productos que se utilicen para lo que
fuese pero que al final tiene que
utilizar estas sustancias las pfeas o
también las pfoas o las PF o s hay
varias sustancias químicas en relación a
la producción esté limitado y controlada
y no solo eso que al final las fábricas
sabemos que tienen un desecho hacia el
agua y puede contaminar el agua entonces
esta regulaciones deben de venir desde
los gobiernos para poder impactar en la
salud pública si no lo hacemos desde
este nivel es muy complicado que podamos
evitar que al final lleguen al cuerpo
hoy sabemos que en nuestra sangre
existen químicos existen antibióticos
que consumimos hasta en el agua existen
productos plásticos y esto tiene que ver
con lo que está alrededor de nosotros no
el consumir
alimentamos tomamos agua utilizamos
productos Entonces desde la instancia de
El Sistema o cada gobierno de cada país
deben estar establecidos que debe de
haber una reducción o una prevención
para el consumo de estos químicos desde
la producción porque como ya lo decían
ustedes desde el principio no existe una
manera de poder evitar que se mantenga
en el ambiente O sea no existe un
sistema que podamos evitar su
persistencia en el medio ambiente y esto
complica muchísimo este estas evitar que
llegue al consumidor entonces las
acciones tienen que empezar desde los
gobiernos para evitar esta utilización
de estos químicos
doctora Roxana Muchas gracias por darnos
luces sobre esta problemática que como
podemos ver Afecta no solamente a
Estados Unidos sino a muchos otros
países en el mundo Así es Natalia una
problemática de la que tenemos que poner
mucha atención Muchas gracias por esta
ampliación en salud a ti Valentina